all right guys bang-bang I am super
excited to have mark here today he has
he's the first person to come on the
podcast who's actually sat on the
pension side of the table and made all
the decisions and kind of look through
everything that we spent a lot of time
talking with here so mark thanks so much
for doing this
thank you for having me yeah for the
like three people who watch this who
don't know who you are
let's just start with kind of your
background and what did you do before
you got to O board investments sure sure
sure
so I come out of the financial world I
back in 1990 who is this literally a
lifetime ago I came out of Kellogg and
actually worked for a couple of banks in
Chicago that Continental which is now
part of the eBay and I got it very very
early days okay I got into
securitization so the create the kind of
creation of asset-backed securities and
so this is like five years after lure he
invented the mortgage-backed security is
that so the great was the most fun thing
in the world cuz you were like in
venting with every deal you were
inventing something and and you know it
was you know so it was really a blast
pretty quickly my at the time boss and
later partner figured out that going
through the whole process with rating
ages etcetera and creating a beautiful
investment great bond was an enormous
amount of work and then we would like
double the work and go to investors and
actually frankly give them all the
upside so we developed we actually
invented a structure investment vehicle
which we're basically a initially
Merrill and later Salomon which became
City would raise capital for us really
off of our credit ratings and our track
record as it got built up and so we
really financed all of our paper through
the structure investment vehicle in
about 2004 I started with with the port
with with a new partner cubic estate as
we started Chicago has had funding to
essentially do the same thing and and
yes
so before we get to oh hey don't I which
was quite a quite an experience you know
I I so I invented all sorts of new asset
classes in SM expertise only cuz I was
kind of first one doing yeah well among
the first people doing it one of them
plenty enough lose precious metals what
sort of place to role in your world
right and so I did the first-ever secure
ization of gold silver platinum both you
know kind of the physical mental and and
warehouse receipts and loans secured by
that did feature films and equipment
leases etc etc so so then you kind of
pop up like Oh eight oh nine and Chicago
said fundings kind of churning along
doing fine that's not so great not so
bad making a decent living and and then
you know the sort of storm came and the
way our vehicle works is we match funded
our assets which was quite unique
right because hedge funds of course have
like Redemption like you know sort of
rapid redemption and and most structured
investment vehicles had a lot of
commercial paper funding like short term
you know kind of ooh super risky balance
sheet all right and so we had our
capital in let's call it lado eight
lasted through 2012-2013 which at that
time literally was forever alright we're
talking right after Lehman failed so
that was permanent capital and what we
did was we moved so we had nice
corporate paper we were able to sell for
97 cents on the dollar which so which
was gold right and we're talking like
September October 2000 right 2008 right
when Lehman failing and what we did was
we we did a few things with the money
but 80 to 90 percent of what we invested
in were see allure was a thing called
CLO which still exists big time today um
actually it's funny in fact my first
boss and later partner in Secours Asian
invented the CLO back ya know back in
1989 or the way he would describe it he
exported financial disaster to the
Japanese by selling them kind of B
pieces but but what a CLO is
is a portfolio of senior secured loans
mostly to private equity owned
businesses and and then the funding
comes from from bonds in different
tranches so maybe the first 60 cent 70
cents is a triple-a first a total money
good no matter like the world could come
to an end and you have some mez pieces
junior capital and finally some equity
and we we did buy some first place but
we we bought a heck of a lot of of the
kind of junior those sort of riskier but
was still with lots we didn't buy the
equity we really couldn't based on our
kind of investment guidelines so we had
nice capital underneath us portfolio
senior secured loans right so right so
high yields unsecured how you can get
crushed okay in a like what we're living
through with covin we maybe should talk
about that a little bit later but senior
loans like these things initially buy
them they're 50 or 50 60 cents later
they were like 10 cents there are days
pop we're literally days where Wachovia
is one of our trading partners would
tell me mark you're the only bid in the
world from SCO vapor okay seven cents
like and right for literally we are view
was these are par bonds we're gonna get
through this there's a lot of garbage
paper out there or the mortgage
derivative paper was complete garbage
and was five cents and deserve to be
five cents right it was best kind of six
like you could spend five and make six
we were spending 10 to make a hundred
and and then you know kind of mid oh
nine late kind of late second quarter
2009 I gotta hand it to him like
Geithner's you know those stress tests
if you recall that that then led to a
bunch of that kind of went on the back
of tarp and led to a bunch of equity
offerings by all the big banks that
completely liquefied everything in our
world okay so all the stuff that was
getting crushed
not on solvency but on just illiquidity
all right just and so beautiful like the
clouds parted and
and our you know 10 cent bonds were back
to 60 cents like that you know like and
all of a sudden it's like holy [ __ ] like
we you know we a and this wasn't a 2 and
20 vehicle like we own the equity so we
were making the money and it was just
freaking awesome
so so that's kind of what led me I know
I'm talking at you a lot here I could
you know so to transition now to how I
ended up at the pension all right um so
we pop out of that whole thing and I I
go from a guy making you know 23 bits on
a few dollars to you know really having
some money and so I kind of wanted to
give back and yeah and you sort of want
to use your skillset and capabilities to
write that's the way I think kind of
everyone should approach this kind of
thing and so yeah I met this guy who
ended up running for governor and you
know and and I started actually writing
about so here in Illinois as you know
and I know we're going to talk quite a
bit about the right we we have a pension
system that on the liability front okay
right was you know all these promises
that could never be kept and is
literally just a complete you know train
wreck that has been in process and very
obvious for 25 years I started writing
about that I even did I did a little bit
of TV which worked out quite well
because I kind of got the nerves out and
local TV and for sort of what happened
later on and then so Bruce rauner gets
elected governor and he asked me if I
want to serve on the pension which we of
course chatted about previously he knew
what the answer would be and so that
starts in 2015 so it's really that's
kind of how I got started there and so
let's talk about the Illinois pension
because I think that it is used
constantly as like the poster child
usually in a negative connotation
especially before you got there right
and so maybe let's just start with how
does a pension like that that is so
largely this like 24 25 billion dollars
when when you were there how does it get
so underfunded like what are the
structural issues that end
leading to kind of when you step then
you're like hey we're already
underfunded like like we're already here
we got to trying to dig ourselves out of
this hole but how does that happen okay
so first off so Illinois has its three
large state pensions at this sorry at
the state level then there's a bunch of
local pension so throughout kind of the
government world like a local police
force might have its own pension a now
normally with teachers there's usually a
unified pension per state which is why
think places like Illinois teachers and
CalSTRS which is the California state
teacher pension how they get so freakin
enormous and so what a pension is is you
take money out of the well first they're
negotiating collective bargaining the
you'll take money out of a paycheck of a
state employee a teacher maybe
university worker and there are some
quarter pensions as well but now they
mostly reside in the kind of in the kind
of government world they are those the
way it should work and the way it really
hasn't yet maybe it has in certain
places certainly not in Illinois is then
in a methodical way okay the state would
match that contribution okay and that
money so that money's getting collected
throughout a career and it gets invested
to help professionally hopefully and and
by the way the problems and pensions
really I would all I really say this
across the country the problems and
pensions really hasn't been on the
assets side it has not been on the asset
side it's been on the liability side and
here's why there was there was no
connection between the the funding that
was coming in through the employees and
through and through more importantly the
employers right the states and the
locals you know local governments etc
and the benefits that were being
promised they were completely
disconnected so what you had was
negotiations all right we're on one side
table you had union leadership doing
exactly what they should be doing I
don't I don't quibble it off they're
trying to get as much money as they can
for the people they represent on the
other side you had buffoons you know you
had like
look come on dude have a calculator like
so no math on one side and perfect math
perfect math on the other side so what
happened was the promises could have
never been kept and then you add on that
the tonic which we're all very familiar
with and you know this happens big-time
in Illinois and this happened other it
has happened other places all Illinois
is a poster child for for kind of
screwing around with the formulas to
fund the pension where politicians love
spending their budgets okay on things
for Kurt you know kind of current you
know maybe that and there's a lot of
good things transportation education
please I mean things that have to be
done and are you know necessary and
right but but so what they would do
these pensions is they come up with all
kinds of ridiculous excuses to not fund
them and you here's the thing when you
as your viewers know extremely well when
you start compounding okay and you take
a holiday in like 1997 alright twenty
twenty comes along you're twenty three I
mean you compounded that son that's how
you end up at forty percent funding and
so really what you're talking about here
is you've got multiple sources of inflow
right so you've got the employees
paycheck there's a portion of that
that's an inflow the state or the the
government is supposed to match in many
cases they either don't fully match they
don't match at all or whatever it is
right there should be inflow which are
not getting that capital and then once
you get the the inflows into what I was
call kind of the asset management pool
that asset management pool then has
grown through the investments that were
made right and so you're basically
making the argument which I tend to
agree with that like step one was retold
employees hey you're gonna get X but it
was impossible to deliver on X and then
step two was when we took the employees
capital and put it into the pool the
states didn't provide a hundred percent
of what they should have provided and
now you kind of have a double win so
just starting out the the pool of
capital that the investment team at the
pension has is lower than what they
should have had and also the
expectations of what they need to
deliver are nearly impossible given what
the union was able to to negotiate is
that kind of a fair setting of the
scenario yeah that's exactly right okay
so you step in and what was the
underfunding status when you took over
as the chairman
so under fight this will sound better I
really don't deserve the Hell House or
good this might sound oh the whole thing
is it's such a ridiculous level I came
in it was by 30% I ended it was 40% and
and and so the reasons for that aren't
it's not any magic that I did I mean I
did I will say this when I got there are
but to take a further step back the
twenty four billion dollars that is
being manages now which is about what it
managed a year ago when I left yeah a
little over a year ago when I got there
we managed 18 billion so we had a nice
warrior run we didn't do stupid things
and we did some good stuff and although
I think really the the great things we
did are even more so sort of in the
future we'll talk about kind of rankings
and and kind of the evidence of the
success we had but the other piece of it
is is that the truth of the matter is
that states occur Illinois big-time and
I'd say states across the country had
done a much much better job they fell
super behind but they've done a better
job keeping up over the last let's call
it ten years okay so Illinois the lab
yo hasn't missed a pension contribution
in quite a while
now so it's a massive growth we had we
had okay we had at least they're running
on the treadmill where you sort of hope
to stay in the same place so that that
occurred and that's kind of where we are
okay and so what was the actuary rate of
return and for those that don't know
actuary rate of return basically is
there's an outside group that comes in
and would say mark you the board the
investment team you guys need to hit 7%
or whatever the number is every year for
the next you know 10 20 years and if you
do that we can compound this money at a
rate that will make sure we have enough
to pay out the liabilities in the future
what was your guy's actual rate of
return
okay so when I took over the
was a discount rate that what was eight
and a half percent alright when I left I
know it ridiculous so when I left them
so I used some of the stuff I used to
write back you know way back in the day
kind of before I ran the pension would
be like come on guys like that's
completely absurd like let's at least
you six like the corporate pension plans
do like I mean and by the way pop the
the biggest joke of this is then and
this is a shame on the accountants I
think big shame on the accounts is that
that rate is determined based on an
expected rate of return on the assets
okay we are at the time right thirty
took what's your thirty to forty percent
funded we don't have assets we don't
have assets so we're using a rate of
return on asset and we don't have assets
and the accountants are okay with this
like in fact accounts force you to do it
like I complain and then feels it well I
mean the accounts this is how it counts
tell us to compute you know pension
liabilities and and by the way what do
that you really hit on the key key point
because that discount rate for all the
actuarial assumptions and there's plenty
of totally goofy ones all right life
expectancy they always get wrong they
always get wrong because they never
assume innovation and people are gonna
live longer but but the key variable is
always a discount right because what
comes out of those collective bargaining
negotiations and contracts is actuaries
absolutely can estimate what the stream
of cash flows are required okay and by
the way that's so that's a number that I
would no use I say look you want to just
get any percent that's your freaking
business okay I'm not doing that I'm
gonna just add the cash flows which by
the way in Illinois is about is between
kind of five fifty six hundred billion
dollars with about 90 billion dollars
set aside okay right no so that's if you
just add the cash flows now right now
when they're discounted that's how you
end up at 120 billion dollars right
because that six hundred comes down to
the 3:20 ish whatever the number is and
right so that's yeah you said earlier
that the pensions have done a good job
over the last ten
my first thought is well that also
happened to nicely coincide with the
longest bull market in history how much
of what I will call the structural
issues or aspects of the financial
system and kind of be inflating through
QE etc of those asset prices over a full
decade do you kind of contribute the
fact that pensions have done better at
keeping up versus is there some other
change that pensions have had in terms
of they've gotten smarter or their
change of strategy or is it literally
just hey we got in the right position
and the market kind of carried us from
there so I don't really think it has
anything to do on the asset side or your
inflation of asset prices which you and
I don't exist that's one place we won't
exactly see eye to eye because I'm not
as sort of skeptical evaluations and but
we'll get to that later really though
but where your question does come into
play though is that you had a you had a
nice economy that kind of just kept
chugging along right the kind of yo was
that sort of work kind of like a
workhorse right you never had the
beautiful 3 4% growth but you had nice 2
steady 2% growth and so tax revenues
grew and so what what what governor's
Quinn around her and now Pritzker all
did I sort of tip your hat to him is you
know you would like to see them reform
the pension because you can never really
catch up but what they did do was they
took kind of all the additional kind of
tax revenues starved the rest of state
government which which may or may not
have been a good idea and probably not
and and all that money just got sucked
into this freaking big you know pension
hairball just sucks in everything and
and I think that really explains so I
think it was they had the money yeah and
so when you stepped in
I really remember this there was a huge
focus on historically pension managers
have essentially gone out found the best
asset managers you know in the world and
they give them the money
and there's all these questions that
fees and structure and risk they're
taking and kind of all the things that
come with who are we giving our money to
and you know was it probably they're
gonna give us back a great return you
took a very different approach and one
that I think now has become a one
replicated in other places but to also
more and more people are starting to say
wait a second like that may be something
that makes a lot of sense so let's talk
through just kind of at a high level
like what the philosophy of the invest
investment strategy is and that we can
get into some more of the tactical
things that you guys did awesome okay so
here's a philosophy is for starters so
pensions allocate asset right we have an
a teo and asset allocation - exactly
what you expect right - stocks bonds
real estate other some pensions might
have commodities might have diversifying
strategies I mean also there's all
different things and then of course
there are subclasses within those okay
the now within so so that's kind of the
top of the stack let's say are the are
the asset classes then sub asset classes
and then how do you get those invested
most pensions allocate invest that money
which we'll call allocating okay invest
that money through third-party managers
that is smart that is a smart way to do
it okay that is smart if I didn't
mention it three times already what you
don't want to build some big investment
team to be picking stocks finding
private equity investments god help you
pensions have done alright in direct
investing in real estate and I saw you
had a tweet last night something was
talked about real estate absolutely in a
little bit when we're drilling down
they've done okay and that and there's a
sort of limited kind of trouble you can
get and let's say with real estate
unless the brother-in-law one of the
trustees right is a developer and you
know you're laughing I'm laughing
because I've read the stories I know
what happens so but like when so when
you took over right there's 24 or 18 to
24 billion dollars somewhere in there
you guys are actually not doing
third third percent quartile of
performance and you basically from what
I understand walked in and just started
saying look let's get into kind of a
just start slashing fees make sure that
we're not spending a bunch of money to
actually get our capital invested and
then you took this kind of discipline
systematic approach that was really
focused on innovation so kind of explain
what that means when you say a
disciplined systematic approach with an
overweight or focus on kind of
technology and innovation got it got it
okay so so the portfolio that I
inherited had to three hundred managers
across right so no pop could you imagine
like it's and by the way it was
volunteer so I was really willing to
really kind of get in I was gonna be you
know I was soon to be elected chairman
and but I mean what are you gonna do
with two or three hundred man
you can't possibly wrap your arms around
it and really we should be focusing on
the top of the stack on allocation and
so right away you know I often say I had
no preconceived notions on things like
hedge funds private equity credit
opportunistic credit real estate etc but
I did have a preconceived notion that
you want to simplify you want to be able
to understand what the hell it is you
have right
you have board meetings quarterly we hit
my II maybe I'll have six a year right
so and you got a lot to do in them and
you've got a limited staff so you want
to simplify and it's like in a million
so I love indexing I indexed about half
my I have my own assets the beautiful
thing about indexing is once you you
take that allocation to top of the stack
I was telling you about you know public
market equities domestic right domestic
internationally right if you do index
there's nothing to do like you're done
you don't need a staff you don't need
you know the board doesn't need to
discuss it you are going to get the
market return right and there's all this
attacking of you know that it's yeah
terrible and you end up owning a bunch
of stuff you know I mean look at the
assets that to this day are the
concentrations in the SPF
so which again we can get to a little
bit later it's like sort of go through
questions so so index what I didn't
realize though is I had no idea
so all pensions pensions operate around
around the government right they're
funded by governments ideally state
pension which is most attention assets
anytime you have government around
you're gonna politics around and early
on like I got some believable I'm
driving somewhere I get a call and I
don't recognize the number of it it's a
lobbyist
it's a lobbyist calling me about some
manager that they hear that we're gonna
be you know reducing shortening the yeah
simplifying the manager roster and I'm
like do you realize you're calling me is
a material piece of data right that will
support getting rid of your whoever
you're calling me about please don't
tell me the name like are you kidding me
like I mean that happened and that by
the way happened more than once and so I
was I I was fortunate in that I had you
know the governor governor's staff were
super supportive of what I do whatever
it is I did I think and so as soon as
those calls went in over there they're
like deal with mark okay and it feels
like as you step in as the chairman like
really you said it already right like
the goal is do we get the asset
allocation right meaning we're gonna
take 10% put it in real say we're gonna
put you know 60% in stocks we're gonna
put in you know here's how we break it
down across all the different indices
whatever it ends up being most people
will then spend tons and tons of time on
well which manager do we select within
this bucket well you're basically making
the argument for and you guys did was
you basically said look if most of
people aren't going to beat the industry
benchmark then why don't we just invest
in the industry benchmark and therefore
yes there might be one or two people who
beat it but we're gonna beat 80 90
percent of the managers in this space
anyways by just investing in the
benchmark it's easier we just buy it we
don't have to go and check on a manager
do a lot of stuff and then
also it's usually much cheaper on top of
that right there's a net and there's an
additional advantage which is so the the
meeting that I was elected chairman of
we terminated so there were four
managers out of the hundreds that were
on watch so I'm like surely if we have
like 200 managers we can we can at least
terminate the four that are on watch and
have been on watch for a year for more
than a year so so sure enough of course
the media was there and there was a re
articles were later yada yada which I
think actually to me they were I think
start out as hit pieces they may I think
they made us look terrific but here's
what I noticed though so in the
investment committee meeting when we
were really getting into the guts of
this one of the trustees on the other
side table I got pretty pissed of like
you know you're yeah we got an RFP for
general consulting because a which was
kind of part of all of this and you
terminate these matters like yeah and
got really pissed and I could say yeah
this is kind of thing that I think
happens over and over often happens
behind closed doors maybe with a staffer
okay who needs a board to like that
anyway once it sort of people chilled a
little bit then we had board meeting and
same kind of you know kind of energy
entered the room lots of heat and then
and so at one point they the vote was
going to be the vote and vote end up
being 6 to 3 and 8 to 1 actually on a
couple of terminations so this trustee
City fine sits down it's like all right
mark what are you putting the money into
and like it's gonna be indexed and all
the heat came out of the room and that's
what gave me the idea to write that
first Wall Street Journal op-ed all like
it indexing not only is a terrific way
to invest okay it also is a beautiful
beautiful governance tool to keep people
out of trouble okay just recently that
North Carolina senator you know Georgia
wherever they are and you know this has
happened kind of over and over we're
right it's like if you index know you
sorta you really become impenetrable
from the peanut gallery shooting at you
and in this case where some manager of
getting terminated
the manager perfectly good people doing
a professional job I never once
suggested that wasn't the case and it
wasn't the case they were just kind of a
little under their benchmark at best
they'd be at their benchmark and I'm
just trying to simplify things and
that's where court ended up and and so
by index and you take the insult out of
it and and the other piece of this pub
is actually so there's a professor
actually is an Arizona State so Neil
Hollow I've quoted a couple times and
some of them so my materials has done
great great academic research which I
kind of got obsessed with on
institutional investor decisions but
this is not just pensions this is
endowments foundations everyone suffers
from this of you're constantly firing
managers and hiring other ones okay
flavor of the month all right and so
it's like beautiful academic research
that in like eighty ninety percent of
the cases the manager you replace that
came in is kind of underperforming their
benchmark as you know within sort of a
year or two and you're just running on a
treadmill you're wasting your time and I
think that maybe was Nevada is where
there was a CIO and he like fired effort
like literally the entire investment
staff and he like put our I remember
exactly eighty ninety percent of the
capital was all in indexes and then he
would just kind of check on it like once
a week and the article I read who kind
of made it seem like you know it pretty
easy life right he was managing a quite
a bit of money so yeah so I I spent some
time with him actually at a we met at a
conference and you know I gave him the
big you know fist bump right out of the
blocks and so he's kind of the opposite
of these we're very similar sort of the
opposite of me cuz I'm this kind of wild
you know right I love talking about what
I'm doing he's gonna the shy guy in the
back of the room but the guy is awesome
and so Tim Martin is a reporter for Wall
Street Journal
who covered pensions and is now in Asia
and he's the guy actually put sort of me
on the map and are and the a little more
importantly Illinois approach on the map
and you know when he wrote that he wrote
the article in kind of March ap wrote
the
he's the one who wrote the article
you're referring to so he put me on the
map with this article of Mark Levine
answering questions for hedge fund
executive at work last week why do I
need you well I don't know if you
remember that article but uh right and
so then the full quote there by the way
was you know this hedge fund guy
literally it with a two to one of our
board members says you know I got the
smartest guys in the world who you know
why would you invest in a brain-dead
index fund I'm like dude I got Apple I
got Microsoft I got Facebook I got
Amazon I got Jamie Dimon and Warren
Buffett allocating my capitals like why
do I need you so he used weathering
anyway and so as part of this Nevada
yeah got it and so would it be fair to
say that pretty much the approach that
you've looked at is unless you were able
to invest in the top you know 0.1 of the
point one of the 0.1% kind of this form
you know three asset managers in each
category unless you're an LP in those
funds that are the absolute cream of the
crop yeah everyone anything else
you're better off going into the index
for all the reasons that you described
right it's kind of like that there is
you know some point one of 0.1 percent
that is that cream of the crop
everything else indexing and you're
pretty much golden at that point if you
get the asset allocation right is that
fair
yes that is absolutely fair and the
first thing I always say is by the way
you're getting some X some noise out a
little bit but you're fine oh good okay
okay sorry so the first thing I always
say pop is is if all you do is index
there's just nothing wrong with that and
you're probably going to be better off
than getting it in most case you're in
the America we actually thought that we
had an approach remember we're twenty
four billion dollars like we have access
to various resources and had an approach
that we believed in which we'll get to
soon right the outs of this outsourcing
model but there's nothing wrong with
indexing that's of course what like
Nevada does they index 90% of portfolio
10% equity oh by the way what I met him
he's like I don't know I'm not sure
about that dent aside but but
anyway the if if I could riff a bit on
public market equity allocation which is
kind of where your questions going the
way I see it if you have I sort of like
to break it up into sort of structurally
and to me the perfect public market
equity portfolio is you start off with a
big big hulking bunch of index get that
you know kind of get that core index
yeah so that you know one thing is you
don't want to screw up so bad right from
you know from sort of doing things on
the periphery which by the way would
include just hiring any active manager
where you end up so far from normal
equity returns that exert that that it's
actually kind of super material to
return to the fun right so so I think
you start off with a big chunk of
passive no matter what late then I layer
on top of that kind of three different
sort of three areas first would be
factors right so fact it's a final
French factors the 1991 paper right one
Nobel Prize led to their their Nobel
Prize that there are a few factors that
are highly predictive right of right
potential outperforms now I don't
necessarily believe that those factors
are value Bauval momentum momentum was
actually a six point and any small cap
so so so you can invest in factors
actually very very inexpensively there's
a and by the way there's ETFs etc for
you know for individual investors yeah
we could pay like two bits to Blackrock
or something like that and you know
which is free and and you have that goes
to the licensing the the other factor
and so what I like there's two things I
like about factors not to do a ton of
but to maybe do 10 / 10 15 percent
number one it's a nice diversification
off of your market cap weighted index
right so look there is some truth that
they may be the weights at the top of
the you know the
the stack of the sp500 right is yellow
now 20 22 % it's kind of been there in
the past that's okay
all right but a nice little
diversification away from that which I
almost kind of use like sort of a
diversification free lunch the other
piece which maybe you'll get a sort of
kick out of is so board members come
onto these boards and they have views
and that's good like there's nothing
wrong with having a view what you want
to make sure is there isn't a view
accompanied by a brother-in-law whom
happens to manage money in a way that is
consistent with that view so factors
give a staff and a board a very
systematic way to to sort of express
views so that's fact its factors chap
part two which we did okay so I'm gonna
sort of change the order just a bit on
how I view it personally but what we got
this deal idiosyncratic investing some
more kind of private equity style
investing there are some guys out there
Seth Klarman a Chris Hahn who and we had
some of these guys in our portfolios who
are just it's just weird weren't Buffett
back in the day okay I'm as disappointed
as everybody believe me with the way
things have gone the last particulars
that annual meeting this year but very
disappointed but but idiosyncratic
investors who don't who are absolutely
all they're looking as absolute return
okay
and concentrate they will tend to
concentrate like crazy Chris on my news
which is TC I might have two names and
it's not fifty you know happens
portfolio he does that all the time okay
and so that's something that we did
quite a bit of we did that it drifted
over to technology which is where our
innovation so the the other piece was we
didn't do which had I stayed on which
I'd had enough believe me but the third
piece when you're thinking about the
structure of a public market equity
portfolio is a kind of themes and this
is where we're actually like your
interview with Cathy woods I just loved
right so think Cathy in that like this
theme of
vation and so that's actually why I
invest my own money so I have this theme
I just I happen to believe in that the
IT departments across the world they're
gonna be completely restructured over
the next 10 years they're gonna move
from on-prem to clap like it's so that's
a thing bio Texas there's all sorts of
different things and right now a theme
is covin right so it's funny I seed like
these ETFs with like Co V DTS [ __ ]
marketing pardon my language where yeah
they're investing leave these vaccine
manufacturer know I know a Kovac
portfolio is Cruise Lines and real
estate like come on guys so anyway so
that's up to me a public market
portfolio and so when you do that you've
got kind of the core in the indexes and
then you've got factors where you've got
the idiosyncratic and then you've got
the the themes one of the big themes
that I think you guys did over the four
years and so for people that don't know
is under your guidance and the rest of
the board the pension went from that
third quartile to top 8% over kind of
the three-year period of all picture
performance so kind of it worked would
be the takeaway from that you guys had
an overweight and a focus on technology
and innovation and so maybe kind of
talked a little bit about how you kind
of arrived at technology and innovation
being that theme and then what you guys
tactically did to get exposure in
technology and innovation okay
which I could tell you I'm a total
genius and right and the staff would
like it
um what we did was we have so we as I
said when we started you know we had
actually 80 hedge fund managers what I
started and we got rid of almost all of
them the ones that survived and really
were part of came third made this was
actually a pretty decent Segway into the
outsourcing side of our model so we used
a firm called Rock Creek to pick all of
our active managers back in there later
we did an RFP and we added hi Vista to
and by the way the portfolio today is
like literally diverse like probably a
thousand base points of Alpha public
market I mean crazy that's how you end
up top 8% last three years top 3% last
year the so
The Rock Creek portfolio and there was a
little bit of nudging from me with with
the folks over there
come on let's concert like I don't want
you to have 16 managers that's too like
narrow narrow narrow and and that's
where some of these idiosyncratic guys
like a like again like a TCI parvis but
also some some managers so these are
matters that were in a portfolio for
quite a while
guys like Tiger global co2 I wish I know
some firms and I like like well Rock and
Sequoia were Sequoia weren't in there
but but we had enough of it that right
so those guys they they fanatically
invested in tech and we sort of watched
it and liked it and and it produced
terrific returns and you know at the
beginning I'm like cracking jokes I'm
like oh you know thanks for investing in
Google for us like I don't think we
could have spa I don't think we could
have spotted that one but the truth of
the matter is it was great that they had
these big big over weights you know
across TechNet yell across technology
and in fact going into small cap as well
yeah and so one thing that's really
interesting to me is and we've talked
about a million times in the podcast of
just the best performing institutions
whether they're foundations endowments
pensions whatever it is they tend to be
overweight innovation like you're
talking about here and normally the way
that they're doing that a little bit of
private equity but really venture
capital is where they're finding a lot
of that and you're kind of mentioning it
here to the tune of you know if you look
at Dietrich Foundation they're like 80
90 percent if you look at something like
GMO I think Jeremy Grantham recently
said he's like 70 percent in his
personal portfolio of venture capital
like such outrageous allocations to the
private markets around venture capital
that obviously a pension can't go do
that but where do you think about in
terms of when you say overweight like
what does that look like are we talking
five ten percent are we talking getting
to you know kind of 20 30 percent in
venture capital like where do you think
for a conservative organization like a
pension is actually realistic if they
want to be overweight they could get to
right so for starters as far as venture
capital goes you're exactly right
that the endowment and you yell of
course is the the poster child of this
right that you know going back 30 40
years right what happened I think I
assume was a lot of these venture
capital firms were operating with the
universities with like the you know the
recklessly the academics of the
universities and that drifted over to
the endowment thank God for those
universities because right some of these
endowments pay right actually met with
with Tim Sullivan who works for David
Swensen a Yale and has been with them
you know almost from day one I think a
40% of Yale's
operating expenses while they're growing
1 billion dollars to 30 billion while
they're doing that ok with a lot with a
heavy venture capital so the problem
though which you you sort of touched on
is that public pensions so the great
venture capital funds are one of two
things they're they might be sort of
larger guys and those guys even a guy
who's raising half a billion billion
dollars he wants to do a ten million
dollars of time he doesn't want to be
dependent on one source okay so that's
number one so you can't get big dollars
out if if you can get in and by the way
we were able to get into some and the
other thing is again this even the
smaller guys rates the problem is the
bite sizes this goes to my point of you
gotta have a structure you got to be
able to manage the damn thing so you
can't have 800 different managers could
you do sort of a fund of funds approach
that that's not a crazy idea at all
and so where we ended up getting our
innovation exposure can not from our
necessarily my decision or but the
result of our decisions we're more in
the public market space which by the way
there's amazing like I don't know that
it's any worse I mean the right if if
you're focusing on a micro small cap
public right public market portfolio on
the make sense and then I guess one of
the things that people are paying
attention to now and we have a lot of
asset managers come on talk about it but
nobody from the pension side is there is
complete
structural change manipulation whatever
going on in the markets out of necessity
so you get interest rates dropping to
zero right through emergency cuts you
get tons of quantitative easing and kind
of the balance sheet expanding at a very
aggressive rate how does that change the
way that pensions think about managing
their assets and part of that ends up
will eventually lead us into the
corporate bailouts and who holds the
corporate debt and all that kind of
stuff
but just from the structural stuff so
interest rates going to zero and tons of
money printing like how does that
actually change the way a pension things
about allocating their capital okay so
I'm really glad you asked that the most
important thing I've talked about this
so much like over the years the most
important thing whether whether you
frankly whether your pension and
endowment found out like frankly an
individual is you the way to win an
investing is to be a long-term investor
by the way in this innovation space god
help you god help you if you think
you're gonna like day trade or even have
like a one year time horizon because
you're gonna get nailed like you could
own the best freakin thing in the world
but you can get nailed at any time and I
tell people if they've got like a three
iView if you have a three year time
horizon that's really not long enough
now five year I think is long enough
okay but you know and certainly I prefer
like never like imagine that you'll
never sell so I think it's really
important for the managers of pension
funds endowments etc to understand that
they are right they are a they're a
long-term investor it's a long game and
what matters in 2020 really isn't that
decisive right it's what the way the
world looks what looks in 2050 and I
sort of feel like you have to be
optimistic and and I am actually
extremely optimistic and and the reason
why what have you asked this is this
fixation on and I'm sure I'm going
countering out of many of your guests
this fixation on standard deviation what
a effing joke what a joke sanitation is
your friend as a pension event it's your
friend I'll explain that explain that
yeah
explain why that is okay so and by the
way that entire hedge fund universe
right sold themselves as a standard like
just horrible
so what standard is it right so VAR eval
your wrist and deviation is your daily
fluctuations in a stock price and a bond
price and what kind of whatever acid is
your Bitcoin and whatever ask that
you're talking about okay and right so
what now what the would that volatility
differ first of all there's state
evasion normally is measuring this daily
volatility that in you know right eight
out of every nine quarters is completely
irrelevant okay and and then gets maybe
gets relevant and like the quarter we
just end it right where or like big big
volatility okay the the stuff that
happens day to day is just total noise
and yet it's discussed right now frankly
I said that places like CNBC Bloomberg
and right and across the hedge fund
world and in boardrooms I even think you
know standard deviation at a time like
today where it's you know cranked up big
time because massive volatility right
you have an S&P dropping by third by
like 37 percent then popping back up I
throw my kid a month down a mother oh my
god and but even that it's it'll end up
being transitory because it's all about
what the earnings are with the power of
the economy and these companies you're
investing in or the real estate projects
that you build or invest them in 2040
and 2050 okay that's that's the game
you're playing right and so this some if
I might riff a bit here hedge funds the
reason for hedge funds are volatility
dampening right right diversifying
strategy it's like and they charge you
know charging is ridiculous amounts for
no returns and it's all about the
standard deviation portfolio it's like
so like what are you getting like what
the way hedge funds in and you know
hedge funds you got to separate them
into the stock pickers and the
derivative books so really talking about
the derivative books who have like
returns are like one
percent right I mean over the last three
years five years ten years they're
horrible right and right fees have come
down a bit it's like it's still a total
waste of time and right but they have
but they dampen volatility it's like we
have bah ants for them there's all sorts
of things right and you know what even
if you believe in having a diversifying
strategy as like I talked about with
factors and the public marketing public
market equity book you're having a five
percent yeah it's like we pay our bond
guys like eight basis points like that's
what it's worth so somebody is gonna you
know it's gonna have a dampen your
volatility that's it's not it this is
not a two twenty fight you pay you pay
big fees ok for big returns right you
actually want volatility you want what's
called tracking error right you have
your board better be ready and error as
an individual you better be ready for a
really nasty quarter right if you have a
concentrated portfolio or you have a
butt cut that might be concentrated in
certain stocks okay like TCI that might
be concentrated a theme like what can't
like what are good you know good Kathy
does we're co2 or type of global you
know what those guys do so right so
that's that's and what you're basically
talking this is always something that
and we'll talk about Bitcoin here a
second but like this is always my point
when it comes to Bitcoin when people say
oh bitcoins too volatile right and I
always used kind of two examples let's
say one volatility is not a negative
thing you need volatility to driver
turns over long periods of time right so
if something's not volatile you'll never
get a return from it yet and yes it
won't go down but it won't go up either
so volatility isn't necessarily bad when
it goes against you it's nasty when it
goes with you then you know it's your
friend but party example the exhibit I
always go back to his Amazon right so
people have heard me say this a million
times but Amazon since it went public
for 20-something years has had a
double-digit drawdown every single year
the average entry year drawdown is over
thirty percent and it drew down over
ninety percent one time but it's one of
the best performing stocks over the last
twenty years
and so what I think you're talking about
here is basically if you have high
concentration and there is volatility
the shorter your time frame that you're
looking at the more likely it is you're
going to see
bad quarter a bad week a bad month
whatever it is but over long periods of
time if you made the right asset
allocation and something is hyper
volatile you should see a very large
appreciation and is actually probably
likely to be one of your best performers
in your portfolio right I agree 100%
with every word you just said okay so
why why should tensions not put Bitcoin
in their ports what's your thoughts just
Bitcoin in general and how pensions one
are looking at it right now and to
either the argument for or against what
that looks like putting you know such a
hyper volatile asset that is new right
only ten years old or so into what is
normally a pretty conservative asset
management environment right all right
so let's some carve this up into various
parts okay so and so I do want your
audience to know like I'm actually the
friend Innes although there may be some
things I say that aren't exactly what
you want to hear so Bitcoin really isn't
ready yet for sure to be a full-blown
kind of asset class so almost view it
like an assembly line okay to get into
to be asset class status and I think
we're years and years away from that at
a public pension at an endowment and
here's what is the first thing that has
that that would need to happen and well
let's leave the merits a hook to the
side okay so we just talked about
Bitcoin as a investable asset okay which
I do believe it is though I don't own
any myself so the first thing is met the
manager you remember your hiring
managers to make your decisions okay
so within the asset classes that you've
established and I when I think about it
there's sort of several different asset
classes you could imagine Bitcoin going
in and we'll get to that in just a sec
so the way this would work is first some
managers would put some Bitcoin in it'll
need to do well unfortunately like the
ballot this is the way it is now like
if right so if a manager puts in submit
coin and it drops by 50% they're not
gonna be talking about it right and and
by the way and I'm ok well I'm not
totally ok with all that and right but
so it almost needs to start becoming an
interesting story to even just register
beyond
some manager you happen to hire who you
let do whatever it is they do invest it
in it and by the way I so I'll tell you
this I'll give you a I'm gonna give you
a win here is if a man if one of our
managers had assumed he was appropriate
within their mandate had invested in
something a Bitcoin I wouldn't have been
upset at all not at all I was up hey
dude it's on you and and by that's kind
of the way you need to operate you're
right I mean you've got again a lot to
manage you can't fix a two-month alright
so next up would so we're talking about
a sort of an assembly line or funnel
where everyone to call the next stage in
my view would be does a board actually
write and actually take let's say a
create a sub asset class so take one of
their categories and I'll bring up three
as I just sort of throw them in you and
maybe I'm sure you have some views take
us take create a sub asset class from
whether it's cryptocurrency digital
currency Bitcoin in particular right
graduate that would be a full graduation
okay from managers happen to do it to
actually say I'm gonna do this okay I'm
gonna do this and and the asset classes
I think about their commodities feel
good to me but of course funny thing
about a bitcoin is if guys like you were
right and the seven have trillion dollar
gold ass said right is ready for these
like right and you got a 30 X or of
value discrepancy in store a value it's
funny that I don't think I need to
explain your audience may be in it may
be your kind of innovation buckets right
so whether that's private or public may
be an innovation manager you could see
it fitting in there and then of course
the last piece is if you haven't
diversifying strategy which is where
these hedge funds are you can totally
see if fitting in there as well yeah so
we went through this exercise we as we
were creating a fund we knew we want to
go talk to Paul pitches and this whole
question of life they have preset
buckets of capital and if you just walk
in and say hey we're gonna do Bitcoin by
itself basically every single investment
team looks around goes okay well bucket
should we take from if we wanted to do
this right exactly we turn about and we
thought that it's almost like paralysis
by analysis right that they just will
never be able to pick because it could
go in each any one of the buckets
whatever so we decided to do was we
actually created a venture capital fund
and then we said hey look we're gonna
put you know 7080 percent of the capital
into traditional venture capital
investments in equity of companies but
whatever and then we will have twenty to
thirty percent in Bitcoin as an
innovation investment right there's no
company that owns bitcoins to can't
invest there was by Bitcoin and hold it
in the fund and what we found was it had
pros and cons so the pros were now
people knew okay venture capital fund I
know exactly where my pool of capital
for venture capital is I know how to
underwrite this it looks very similar to
other things I've done like I don't have
to kind of build new muscle memory but
it brought into question which was kind
of one of the cons and not really a
total con but but this definitely was an
obstacle was people saying hey do I
actually want to have an illiquid
vehicle that has a liquid investment in
it right so do I want a bunch of capital
investment that's got a liquid asset in
it and so it was very funny to kind of
see while solving for one thing you now
bring up another question but you know
obviously we've got the two public
pensions in Virginia that who kind of
came across the line but they're the
only two so out of the you know hundreds
of pensions in the United States there's
only two you know we kind of sit back
and think all the time and say look is
that a win or is that you found two very
forward-thinking CIOs who kind of happen
to be the tip of the spear and then
everybody else is you know it's gonna
take five years for them to cross the
cross
okay so puck so let me carve that up
again first of all I think you've found
some innovative thinkers I think that's
what I think that explains 100
explanation okay
yeah first sir who happened to find
open-minded people all right
and I'm not casting any dispersions on
everybody else it's hard when you're
imagining you know a ton of money too
but but here's where I will actually
take on subview because the
conversations you had I had I banged my
head against the wall equally on
different topics so for example like we
built in a percent allocation to an
asset class called opportunistic credit
where and there was there's always
hand-wringing of like what you know is
it fix it you know it's illiquid oh is
it fixed income that's mostly liquid
isn't it private equity it's not equity
I'm like guys we're targeting 15%
returns it's unleveraged it's mostly
first lien come on like you can't let
accountants run the world
like what and I would say that in Johar
Faraday our wonderful CIO and now
executive director we got mark that's
just not the way what and so she sort of
managed me it's like I'm chairman board
and but but the accountants sadly do
have enormous power and and those
challenges also like consultants you
know are so so important in that hope so
for what it's worth my way is I just a
quick segue there are many many pensions
we're consultants consultant might run
the pension really where the boards are
that and staff are almost is kind of
just evaluated really rubber-stamping
and and and I'm not even saying that's
bad okay but it is I mean it's just the
way it is and but in any event okay
every board it's only Warren Buffett
attacks rightfully and hysterically a
tax consultant yo he'll talk to you know
a pension board about like why yeah why
did you just simplify your life and why
you hire those consultants and they nod
nod nod and they go on and
we're we're we're puppets wrong though
is unique consultants the board needs
consultants to get a piece of paper so
that when you know right the media comes
the potential litigation whatever it is
you've gotta have that piece of paper
and and that is a value and you're not
gonna find somebody that wasn't more
kind of shake the system up than me and
I believe that so yeah and nothing
Buffett to your point I think Buffett is
talking specifically about the financial
investment perspective what you're
talking about is that's only one piece
of it because you also kind of have to
cover your ass as well to make sure that
you've got other people looking at it
right that's right so it is total
nonsense and it's I mean it's
particularly nonsense and what you what
you had where you're trying to go into a
private market portfolio and something
happens to be more liquid it's like
that's a good thing like use your brain
a little tiny bit the fact it's liquid
if you're targeted you know you've got
targeted returns you got tight and right
the fan look venture capital firms are
holding public stocks all the time right
when after post IPO they're not they're
locked up and they sometimes they hold
even longer than that the private equity
fund so that's complete nonsense I mean
come so so yeah but there is this um
right this this the now so what are the
pension funds that that that investment
Fairfax County Police pension and the
Fairfax County employee retirement
pension so now you've got like a right
you got a beachhead and and to your
point they invested in the first fund
and Bitcoin went up one was one hundred
percent so there's a story around hey
that was actually a pretty good decision
that we made right and and I think that
they already believe kind of like you do
overweight technology innovation private
market you know like there's a kind of a
culture of doing that internally and so
again when they first made the
investment you know you're talking 20
basis points 30 basis points the
portfolio like literally
said this to me right and I'm forever
grateful for them but I gotta imagine at
some point they were like stop bothering
me with you know the 20% to 20 basis
point you know problems right I got much
bigger things on the horizon not to
we'll come back to this in a sec but but
I have to use that point as a tangent to
I don't you saw the Forbes piece I wrote
a few years ago on this topic of well
you just described point zero point
three or zero point four percent that's
actually what pension fund boards who
meet quarterly okay will spend all of
their time on is zero point three
percent of this or totally immature this
is why actually we out so that the third
of our portfolio that we didn't index
that were you know mostly private market
assets but also you have some public
market as we've discussed with what
turned out to be an innovation bias
right the what we end up doing with
those guys because we right we we know
that there are two fundamental problems
to public pension there's the risk of
political meddling and there's also this
just resource-constrained eight that you
just can't spend you know you can't
build some huge team if you do it'll
right if they'll all get fired when the
next governor is elected or something it
just isn't a sustainable strategy so my
view was let's find two or three great
great firms that do this all day long
Pam and it's a great the greatest value
in the world we pay them a few basis
points okay and we end up in also and
again like I said we actually cut three
percent last you know trailing year I
mean I you know thousands of bases like
I should have hundreds of basis points
of alpha and through sort of so so it's
anyway the zero point three that's
actually the business model benjamin's
which is ridiculous so so we can let me
ask this about Bitcoin what do you think
has to happen if you had a say like here
are the milestones that for those that
don't understand the pension world very
well they've never met with somebody in
the pension world like what do you think
the milestones are that Bitcoin has to
hit in order for pension investors to
take it more seriously as how open right
people hate when I say that but that's
essentially what it is right now it's
this you know 150 to 200 billion dollar
asset makes a lot of noise
but it's pretty small compared to
everything else they're looking at and
there's some teams maybe that have
started to get up to speed on it but not
a lot so what do you think has to happen
in order for it to be taken it's kind of
a more serious opportunity with the
large cap allocators in the world okay
so I'm going to answer that question for
how I would look at it but I but I kind
of think that that would I think what
you'd end up with is once it got adopted
once you had a let's say a bigger
beachhead what what could happen I mean
and this is what happened within the
hedge fund space which is very very
similar it might because no one kind of
understand what hell's going on there is
once is there's a lot of copycat right
so once it's accepted maybe with a one
of the Great's so that could be a yell
and down you're one of the like major
endowments or better two or three or
four or five a Texas teachers I'd like
to think Illinois say for investment is
B my right maybe I stay there Wisconsin
whatever like a sort of respected
investor okay so what does it take to
get a van right to me is the question
right to get that real heavy heavy
beachhead and I thought a little bit
about that actually of just over in fact
over the past couple weeks so these use
cases to me to me okay so Amazon starts
have selling books okay and people make
fun of them yeah you're putting like I
used to joke it's like Jeff you know
puts a five dollar bill in a books and
sends and since its customers right and
there are a many went to CDs and toys
and booth yeah I can and then like sell
it right now I think a double you guys
might be the most important business in
the world right it was right dumb just
kind of kept knocking off use kit like
and you all that like all the greats all
the greats did that and I knew Bitcoin
exactly the same way like so I was
watching that
[Music]
and Horowitz woman it's some beautiful
30-minute which got everyone should
watch you go through some use cases of
like remittances like remittances and so
seeing that like in size you know
diverse it's like to me diversity of
usage right so so so that would be one
right and you know so there's stories
like all the underbanked right and so
I'm a square investor so I have I guess
sort of kind of Bitcoin exposure sort of
that way the so like having use cases
that are really robust that are that you
have metrics that you can really prove
okay you can prove now that the things
you've already knocked off I'm sorry I'm
saying you as the human Bitcoin well
you've already knocked off is you do
have I think I'm really thriving like
infrastructure you're on the technology
investment side that's fabulous right
think about actually how stupid is it
sorry I'm sorry I'm getting negative but
how stupid it is then you do have
pensions and endowments dying to get
into some of these venture capital funds
that are making these Bitcoin
infrastructure investments right that
really if you're a true investor which I
fancy myself as though they are not
going to work if Bitcoin doesn't work
okay it's just so you're sort of doing
it already and that's a but that my
friend is a good fact okay that is a
good fact to ultimately get to that kind
of case to let's say of like sub asset
class status so robust multiple use
cases Ida I mean you're talking my
language was a volatility no sweat
okay no problem at all volatility is you
you should expect and is a good thing
you wanna get lucky okay and have good
experiences for people and I know some
people are worried about things it
sounds like this criminal stuff is
completely s that that's some kind of
concentrated you said
the the way you want to definitely be
able to pound like when people bring up
this there's a few whales that control
this thing and they manipulate the
market
you got it has be able to beat the crap
out of that right you can't have those
negative stories that will screw you
okay you right you wanna you gotta get
rid of impediments so yes and and again
just like you did I think you did a nice
job of finding it you got to find a home
for it these are difficult to make the
accounts happy you gotta make the
consultants happy and so does I
hopefully that ya know it I think you
know and I think part of it too is what
we've seen not in the pension world but
I think in the more like endowment
foundation world is there's almost this
sense of this is the ultimate venture
bet it's either worth incredible amounts
of money or it's not gonna work at all
right and so if you go to them and you
say hey take 10% of your assets and go
put it in this ecosystem they're like
get out of my hat you know get out of my
room right if you instead say to them
put 50 basis points to 100 basis points
in this and it's going to not only go
just into Bitcoin itself but it's gonna
go into the ecosystem right there I
think the way that most people are
looking at it is over the last five six
years that has been an incredible
investment because it's appreciated so
much it's been a non-correlated assets
you want in a portfolio maybe that
continues maybe it doesn't but if I put
50 basis points of my assets in and it
goes to zero I'm mad Rex I want to lose
money but you know my life's not over we
didn't lose all the money if that 50
basis points now provides 500 plus basis
points of alpha in my portfolio now I
look like a genius right and so I think
that it's this really interesting asset
that provides a lot of opportunity but
to your point I do think that it tends
to kind of find an audience with people
who already have an innovation kind of
mindset technology that that type of
interest that's where Bitcoin is really
kind of finding an institutional world
yeah and that's really what bitcoin is
like
it righty that's how Bitcoin would
become successful is when you write this
so I would actually watch your debate
with the ship like this this asinine
argument about gold the gold guys are
way weirder they're way weirder than you
guys okay
the gold guy like he's talked about
jewelry jewelry it's like seven half
trillion dollars and you're talking
about Julian
like jewelry is pretty but it ain't
seventy have trillions pretty okay
and the industrial uses are tiny I mean
come on
so we already have an example right of
why is gold worth what it's worth
because it is right good because there's
enough buyers and sellers on both sides
that you're creating diversification
right big I mean that's a that's kind of
where I go where I keep going is having
lots and lots and lots of places to go
for liquidity let's say diversity of
uses diversity of right of buyers and
sellers and negative and positive it's
all sort of beautiful and and for sure
it would be idiotic to go in and pitch
10% of you know put 10% of an
institution and institutional investors
money right because think about it
they're definitely gonna be on the front
page of the newspaper okay if they're
gonna be on the front page when they
make the investment god help you if the
thing drops by 10 percent like then it's
like you're an idiot you threw away the
money what's he doing that's right
you're right so no one's gonna do that
it's like you walk before you can run
and oh yeah and that's we're all so
that's why I kind of bring up some asset
class is MIP you can thrive it's uh
basically there's an argument private
equity is a sub asset class of equities
and here they're doing okay so one
person you could have a 1% allocation
what I kinda like in a sick way is is
use nonsense about paying like let's
think about like diversifying strategies
or even commodities of paying like a 2
and 2001 a 10 or whatever
Bitcoin something you could get exposure
to virtually
for free you can just open an account or
you can have a manager like there's so
many different ways to do it it's not
necessarily like a promotional vehicle
which I hate okay and I think that's I
think that's quite helpful as I think
about never really thought about that
before so yeah I love it
the last thing I want to finish up
talking about is there's tensions across
the country that are super underfunded
in you know I think emails on the head
earlier you can have literally the best
investors in the world invest in the
capital it's gonna be very difficult if
not impossible to actually get to a
fully funded status in the next 10 15
maybe even 20 years what how do you
think about we've now seen a number of
calls for government bailouts of the
pension system right and I've seen a
couple of different kind of proposals if
you will or informal proposals as to how
it would happen but the general idea is
hey the pension doesn't have enough
money to pay its liabilities and
therefore if the airlines are gonna get
bailouts and you know the MTA is gonna
get bailouts and basically the
government just going to become the
sugar daddy for for a bunch of these
different industries why not bail out
local governments and pensions and state
pensions and things like that like how
do you just think about that and do you
think that's possible like do you think
that actually could happen I think it
will happen but not exactly the way
you're describing or it'll be the
Republicans will all call it a bailout
and the Dems will be pissed about
various other things and it's the only
way here's the here's the thing is
potholes must be repaired traffic lights
and street lights have to work like
governments have to operate children
need to be educated ok please like yeah
so so ultimately they had you could have
water whatever waterfall you want ok
that's happening first all right by the
way bondholders are always going to get
screwed and maybe should be screwed in
the kind of I view the waterfall as
being you know that's the potholes and
all
that comes first the pensions come
second whether you agree or not I'm not
saying I want that I'm just saying
that's just the way it is and then and
then bondholders come third the fact the
truth is that it's not just Illinois
that many many many states and on the
local level is you can worse they hit
they were even worse at math if that's
possible and so you have these
situations where all across the country
services are being caught like you're
firing active policemen to pay a pension
to his dad who was a blue who was
retired ten years ago it's so stupid and
you know right and so there are so that
so somehow that but you do have a
contract with these people and they do
depend on the pitch like I get the other
side of the equation - it's not this is
not you gotta kind of try to put the
politics to the side a little bit to get
to a fix and the fix would be would be
reducing pension benefits almost like as
sort of a like a PBGC type thing okay
we're for sure some baseline gets
protected the first 30,000 $40,000
something right people have to eat and
write the I don't want to be dependent
on a cola on these three percent raises
which is a big part of how pension what
they will do this again one day will go
into really into the freakin weeds on
all this stuff but yeah they're
certainly pensions that are over seventy
five hundred thousand dollars
certainly all these raises I mean all
this stuff anything that was gimmicky
like the end of career spiking which
we'll talk about maybe on a future show
right that would there's no way you can
get right Washington to come in for a
bailout okay if you're not pounding the
you know really pounding this thing so
that it's not some freebie and the other
thing you really have to do is exactly
what PBGC does which is you'd have to
cut like lock the pension down where
it's you know kind of it doesn't
continue
stop digging the hole deeper which is
something I used to write and talk about
a lot so you stop digging the hole
deeper you work you work on the benefits
side the state has to do whatever it was
going to do I mean you know so stupid
like we had this pretty good pension for
Bill that end up getting tossed and but
but naturally because it's legislators
they cut the pension contributions from
the say this back in like 2000 I think
13 or 14 they cut the contribution while
they were doing this very sensible
things kind of around the edges which
even some Union guys have come to me and
said that was actually fair but and then
the Illinois Supreme Court just toss the
whole thing and we're back to the square
one which is just absolutely horrible
which is why the only so and by the way
the way they tossed it and this is a
really important fact is that our the
Illinois State Constitution which was
amended after the beatles broke up so
1970 so these are this is not like James
Madison and Thomas Jefferson okay these
are the state legislators a bunch of
clowns okay anyway the state so the
state constitution and many others
around the country say pensions can't be
diminished or impaired so they're
literally saying that a local school
board okay this is the magnitude of the
problem a local school board could get a
raise to a teach can pay a
superintendent four hundred thousand
dollars give a raise your teacher in
their last year to two hundred thousand
have one year of bad but right and that
a legislative state legislature and a
governor can't undo what has locals it's
insane it's a even Jerry Brown former
governor of California told it like
totally agrees with that so what would
so all the things I'm talking about in
exchange for federal money okay and I
know now you're I bet your twitter is
gonna go nuts on that but I'm not saying
it should be a bailout I'm just saying a
grand bargain
of fries reduce fairly protect okay and
in exchange for right for for some
freakin meaningful federal money yeah
and
part of this is I think that I go to the
mindset of like if I could choose
anything don't print any money right
don't bill anybody out whatever but if
you're gonna do it right which at this
point is a foregone conclusion find a
way to give it to the people rather than
go stuffing in every corner of the the
nooks and crannies of the financial
system where you know who knows what the
hell happens to it and it feels like a
pension right is actually a pretty fair
way to in a pretty obvious way to get
money into the hands of people who
frankly do a job in many cases where
you're a fireman a policeman a teacher
whoever you've done a job that is
essential to society but doesn't get
paid like it is in many cases right
a hundred percent of what really talking
is the human side of the equation we're
right you want to go after the excess
right nobody agrees that somebody who
was a teacher for 25 years making 80k
let's say great fantastic then becomes a
superintendent for their last five years
makes 400k a year and now as a four
hundred thousand dollar pension the rest
their life if you went to a New York
life or Vanguard or somewhere for that
annuity that's a ten fifteen million
dollar annuity okay like no one thinks
that's right so right so I told but I
totally agree with you like keep it fair
the money is actually going to get
pumping it's so unfair to like the
policeman or a teacher where they're
making some normal amount of money they
kind of live their whole life my mom's a
teacher okay long retired now right now
her she always knew that pension was
there it was a major part of her
decision-making and as your teacher in
Florida so I shouldn't get sort of the
beautiful pensions that you get in kind
of other places but it's it's good so I
completely agree and and what I'm saying
is oh I say these things than ever it
like everyone hates me want to cut our
benefits and then the yellow and
something's got to be done yeah and I
think that's the key piece right it's
like hey what is going on right now is
unsustainable obviously and so what
you're really almost saying is
like what's saying a great deal is where
both sides walk away feeling like they
gave up a little too much yeah and it's
like that's actually probably what
happens in that scenario right is you
know look you're not going to get the
100% of ridiculous things that you've
been promised instead you may only get
85% which by the way eighty-five percent
means pretty damn good deal right and
then also there is some government
funding that ends up coming in and kind
of making up the difference of whatever
needs to be done and then I think to
your point on top of that is if you can
also then improve the management of
assets not really by doing crazy things
it's actually by doing really basic
things right and kind of doing that
across the board you actually might have
kind of light at the end of the tunnel
you may be able to get there or at least
get much closer to where you need to be
and it kind of feels a little rational
right like it doesn't feel like anything
and there's that crazy in terms of of
how it would play out I always say it's
like you just want him this is like
running a pension you just want to make
more good decisions than bad ones right
and you just want to the thing the first
day I met with the executive director
after I was appointed floor and I said
the only thing the one and only thing I
will promise you I will at all times be
massively rational and that's all we're
talking about here just be trying to be
smart none of this is actually like
super like rocket science right yeah
absolutely
listen I appreciate taking so much time
this is absolutely amazing and I think
that your track record well there's the
chairman was was incredible obviously
speaks for itself in terms of going from
the third quartile to a top 8% top 3%
what uh if you could leave one piece of
advice for investor sitting at home who
haven't had the experience you've had
kind of managing large capital pools and
going across asset allocations like
what's the one thing that you've learned
over your career that youths like this
is the number one piece of advice I'd
give to every single investor if I could
actually say well just say like you just
use your common sense long-term
perspective don't try it
if you're confused don't do it right
just use right
and and you're actually gonna probably
you're gonna probably get to a good
place if you just use your common sense
this is not if some people something
sounds super complicated it's probably
not great I love that that's such a
simple but important piece of advice
that I think people would do well listen
to that I finished up each episode
asking two questions the first is what
is the most important book you've ever
read I'll give you two if I could Atlas
Shrugged and I think was the making of
American capitalists which was Roger
Lowenstein's Warren Buffett like look
through all the transitory right and
yeah I love both of those and the last
question is a little bit more fun and
then you get to ask me a question to end
it but the the last question is aliens
believer or non-believer Wow believer
why what a great question
what why a believer I'm a believer as
well but why just mathematics you
multiply something a billion times a
million times a billion times billion at
some point there has to be some cell
that combined with another cell
somewhere right like we can't be the
only ones with these thermal that like
vents or whatever the heck it is I
couldn't agree more I couldn't agree
more
what Oh what one question do you have
for me to to finish this up so you might
not my question for you would just be so
you know Mike sort of my Bitcoin point
so I'll go to your to you know you saw
your sweet spot is how far do you think
we are from really having robust
diversify use cases and real being able
to walk into a room with you know across
the table from an institutional Wester
and like this you know this is real so
I'll give you two answers one is on the
use case side in terms of users
themselves if you go and you look at the
adjusted on chain annual volume so this
is basically people using Bitcoin on the
Bitcoin now
work doesn't include any the
exchange-traded volume and it also
accounts for anything where it's being
used on chain but it goes to like these
large exchange wallets rights like that
so it's really trying to get out like
true what you and I would consider like
users of Bitcoin as a medium of exchange
if you take that number it is larger on
an annual basis than ven Mo's annual
volume n PayPal's annual volume and also
Apple pay so basically you have an asset
that if it's just a medium of exchange
right a currency it's bigger than many
things that you and I probably use on a
daily weekly or monthly basis right in
terms of technology that we understand
now the big question is where is that
happening so I always joke and I say you
know look in the United States the
dollar base system works pretty damn
well for you and I right like we don't
have a I don't have a fear waking up
tomorrow about like the money's not
gonna be in the bank right or that the
dollars gonna fail and drop by 50% of
course we're very fortunate in that
sense but there's a lot of people
elsewhere in the world that are either
worried about somebody ceasing their
assets the currency failing like all
this crazy stuff right and so I think
that actually Bitcoin becomes this like
no-brainer when you need it right and so
I recently had a woman come on the
podcast who's a founder in the space and
investor but her family's lives in
Lebanon and so right now the the Lebanon
currency the Lebanese currency is you
know phone off a cliff right and so
there's a bunch of capital controls
being put in place like literally
there's protests in the street they
burnt down banks like that all this
stuff and she's like look the
conversation throughout the entire
country is two things one they want
dollars but they can't get them right so
they they they understand the quality
and the stability of a dollar and
everything that comes with it this can't
get access to everything find it there's
a dark market like all this kind of
stuff it's dangerous to go get it
whatever so the next thing is like hey I
got an internet connection like what is
this Bitcoin thing and so it's this
weird thing we're like that's a fringe
use case right because there's only so
many places in the world where the
currencies failing or there's issues
what I do think will happen over a long
period of time and again that may be 20
plus years is every day there's a couple
more people that end up opting and
opting in opting in some of them out of
necessity some out of the out of kind of
interest or entry
so I think that that use case where the
the volumes and the user base will
continue to grow pretty pretty
aggressively over the coming years in
terms of walking into the institutional
world there's two things that have
surprised me so I probably last year
took 120 flights so I don't how many
meetings I did but you know American
Airlines say dude 120 flight so I knew a
flew a lot of places talked to a lot of
people and the two things that surprised
me were one
how many CIOs I talked to had endowments
foundations and pensions that held
Bitcoin individually but did not have it
in their portfolio at work and I would
ask them why and like well I basically I
believe in it I kind of you know
speculated a bunch of different things
but there's zero chance I could go to my
board right now and have a conversation
about Bitcoin right so kind of that that
kind of cover-your-ass everything we
talked about like that was one piece
that surprised me that they had it but
they they didn't go to the boards with
it the second thing was I was surprised
at how many CIOs and investment teams
were more interested actually in the
equity of the infrastructure than the
asset itself and so I you know asked him
why and then it made sense of their like
look we've just seen this a million
times before every time that there's
some new thing when we invest in the
infrastructure we end up making money
and so like I don't know if this asset
meaning bitcoin is gonna end up being
successful or not but like the
infrastructure always works for us and
that's where we're comfortable we can
cover our ass cuz we're buying equity in
a private company and you know yeah or
whatever I think you make a great point
of like well if the infrastructure ends
up being valuable that means that the
assets probably going to be valuable I
don't think that that connection is
necessarily been made yet and so I see a
lot of capital flowing into the venture
capital firms and things like that I
don't see especially the pension level I
don't see a lot of people buying Bitcoin
itself either through managers or
directly the kind of shame of that in a
way is that there's then this drag this
fee drag right and also smexy and
there's both loads of execution risks
right now and surely not every Bitcoin
infrastructure play is gonna where I
mean more than half know if they'll
guaranteed right so why not just sort of
have the thing itself if that's your
thesis
cut out the noise and again there's
nothing wrong everybody there's nothing
all wrong with investing Bitcoin
infrastructure obviously but it's saying
that it's sort of that's so inconsistent
but you know it is they have a basket
for the accounts the damn accountants
went again I couldn't agree more man all
right mark listen thank you so much so
much for for doing this is fantastic I
think people learn a ton you've got some
some life experience and career
experience there that people just don't
get so I'll have to do this again in the
future for sure beautiful thanks so much
for having me I really really enjoy it
great